it's 7:30 time to get ready for school
but in this Salford household in
northern England it's no easy feat
Sloane Warrick and her big family live
on around 200 pounds almost 280 dollars
per week that's all they have four bills
and food but at least their rent has
covered six kids it's hectic he's mad
it's crazy
I've got my should ever got school bags
schoolbooks really Box PE kids it's not
even time to leave yeah that was that
speaking it's fun Sloane's children go
to four different schools the family
lives solely on state welfare benefits
and so having a car is out of the
question
Sloane's partner kevin has provided some
relief
he's currently after the job still
Sloane has faced worse when my
ex-husband left left with the six
children everything no money coming in
and it was a case of okay I'll go
without food I will live on toast and
coffee so my kids can have that can of
beans or they can have that little bit
extra pasta so yeah we do make
sacrifices Sloane's experience is not
unique almost a third of all children in
this area live in poverty that means
their household income is less than 60%
of the annual British median income over
the past five years the number of people
living in poverty in the UK has risen
children's charities say that increasing
living costs and cuts and state benefits
have left many families without
sufficient support Sloane's children
have become used to doing without I like
being surrounded by them just not all
the time
but the lack of privacy is just a small
problem Zack remembers when his father
left and his mum was forced to go to a
food bank I thought the world was going
to end because I thought it was going to
just have nothing to live on and no
electric or anything so that she's now
used to it so now I know what to do you
know that some people can just stick the
kids into grammar schools or private
schools because they can't afford to but
then oh see asana on a low income
we just we get by simple as that we get
by and we deal with it we build a
resilience Sloane hasn't built that
resilience alone her neighbors have also
been there for her every week they come
together to talk about their problems it
helps them deal with the realities of
poverty poverty by definition is
isolation
it is the stripping away of a person's
ability to join into a society that can
be in a very physical way and the people
can't join in and participate in life in
the ways that they would like or they
need to but also there isn't that there
is a shame engendered by poverty which
people can self isolate knowing these
people have got my back
obviously Easter it's a sense of
security it's a sense of belonging
and yeah that's what they like it's a
sense of belonging
Sloane also volunteers at a food bank
Brian Langdon has come to pick up some
basic supplies delays to benefit
payments and changes to the UK's benefit
system have seen a rise in referrals to
food banks according to anti-poverty
charity the Trussell trust at this food
bank numbers have gone up I'm just
struggling just not enough in the house
after paying rent and electric and all
the other bills thought a virgin a doll
have any look she thought dough on the
phone
so it's basic that's how you got survive
I've been in this situation I've had
nothing and I want to know that I can
make a difference and make people feel
welcomed with a little help from Kevin
Sloane is trying to give her children a
structured upbringing they eat dinner
together every day at five o'clock and
there are set bedtimes the Gulf my
children is not to be in pave not to be
in debt I'm to be happy and not
struggling at the same time she knows it
will be hard for her children to break
out of a cycle that's trapped so many in
Britain